Okay, so, I just had you implement your own HTML escaping
function and then promptly showed you that you didn't actually have to
do that, because it was already built into Python. Well, the
exercise is important, because now you know what actually goes into the
escaping function that's built into Python. But you should probably use
the one that's built in, because it's been written by professionals and
seen by thousands of people and used in production, so it's probably
pretty safe. If you don't use the safe one, sometimes you can
run into trouble, like we did at Reddit once. So,
we had our own HTML escaping function, nearly identical to the
one you just wrote, except it had a few extra features
in it, because we had a few extra features in our
comment pages. Now we, at one point re-wrote this function in
C, from Python, because C is much faster and we needed
that function to be particularly fast. Well, when we open-sourced Reddit,
we did a quick scan of our code for security holes,
and, we weren't too concerned about this because most of Reddit
is written in Python which is a fairly secure simple language.
C, that's not quite the same case. So, on the day
we open-sourced Reddit, somebody found a security hole in our HTML
escaping function that we wrote in C. It was only like
20 lines, but within there, there was a hole. And, it
was super embarrassing. We fixed it right away, but it just
goes to show, you know, unless you have a really good excuse,
you should probably just use the built-in functions. Otherwise,
you're going to end up looking like dorks, like we did.